the planned acquisition of my envineo in
the introduction of both ibm cloud for
education and ibm websphere automation
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements from ibm cloud
start things off this week we're excited
that ibm has announced a definitive
agreement to acquire mayanvenio
a process mining software company this
is big news for the ibm automation
business because process mining is
frequently the starting point for
success
when it comes to ai powered automation
my enveno's process mining technology
helps you identify the business and i.t
processes that can benefit most from
automation
and it even allows you to simulate
future processes so you can gain
confidence in the changes and understand
their impact
when my envino capabilities are added to
existing workflows decisions
rpa content and capture capabilities
we'll be able to offer a one-stop shop
for implementing
enterprise-wide intelligent automation
with my envineo we're anticipating that
we'll be the first vendor to offer such
a complete and integrated set
of end-to-end ai-powered automation
capabilities
to learn more about mayanvenio and the
planned acquisition see the blog linked
in the description of this video
next up i'd like to introduce ibm cloud
for education
a targeted cloud solution for the
education industry
as educational institutions transition
to more remote learning
it's critical to make computing lab
resources accessible off-campus
that's why ibm has been working with
higher ed institutions to build a
virtual lab infrastructure
we're also launching the ibm cloud for
education applications lab
the applications lab provides a fully
managed cloud-hosted computer lab
environment
delivered as virtual desktops and
pre-loaded with software applications
as a fully managed service built on ibm
cloud bare metal servers
it relieves educational institutions of
the entire overhead of managing and
maintaining their infrastructure
the solution is perfect for any
institution looking to offer remote
access to computer labs or specialized
software to their students and faculty
best of all you can try out the service
for free with the light plan
check out the blog link below to learn
more about ibm cloud for education and
the capabilities it provides
to finish up this week let's take a look
at the all new ibm websphere automation
which allows you to automate websphere
operations to quickly unlock value with
increased security resiliency and
performance
ibm webster automation aims to deliver
value into existing websphere
application server environments
this can help you reduce the cost effort
and risk of addressing common
vulnerabilities
automating tasks and remediating
capacity incidents
by removing manual toil we want to help
your team spend more time innovating
you'll also minimize the cost of
extending the life and maximize the roi
of your websphere investments
websphere automation is available as a
standalone offering whereas in addition
to the ibm cloud pack for watson ai ops
if you'd like to learn more about the
offering hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloudnow if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description of this video and again
please don't forget to subscribe to our
channel to stay up to date on what's
going on in the cloud
now
you